it's yours it serve you well and your
children after you
[Music]
can I be Lord of a holdfast you will
marry a high Lord and rule his castle
and your son's shall be nice and princes
and Lords no that's not me you flowered
my dear no more i mother told me but I
thought it would be different in what
way I thought it would be less less
messy wait until you birth a child
you're a woman now do you have any idea
what that means I'm fit to bear children
for the king a prospect that once
delighted you bringing little princes
and princesses into the world the
greatest honor
Oh Queen what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season 8 discussion video I won't
necessarily call any of this my
predictions or theories but this is
something I want to talk about with all
of you and I'm interested in seeing some
of the feedback that I get also the
third Prize winner for the giveaway has
been randomly selected and I will
announce your name at the end of this
video today I want to talk about the
future of House Stark I had the idea for
this video before season 7 started but I
didn't end up making the video because
gray area who is a really good friend of
mine also had the idea for this video at
the same time and I didn't want to
release something too similar to hers in
the same week so I figured I would wait
to talk about it later now that there is
only 6 episodes left I do think it's a
good time to discuss what is going to
happen to House Stark who is going to
carry on the family name
after all the current Starks died the
main thing that influenced this video
was when I was rewatching season 6
actually as I was watching the scene of
Arya Stark getting stabbed by the wave I
was wondering how bad these injuries
actually were everyone knows that she
magically recovered within days
but when the wave stabbed her and
twisted the blade I was wondering what
could this have done to Arya's internal
organs I'm obviously no doctor so I'm
not even sure if this put her in any
danger of reproducing or not but I was
thinking she might not be able to have
kids because of these stab wounds then I
started to think about the rest of the
Starks and as of right now I'm not sure
if anyone will be able to carry on the
family name for their great house there
is only six episodes left so it's not
like we even have a lot of time to see
how stark flourish in the future but it
would be nice if there was a little sign
of hope in the finale maybe some kind of
scene to let the fans know that the
house will have future heirs with the
stark name now whether that's by one of
the Starks getting pregnant by the end
of season 8 or one of the Starks getting
married by the end of season 8 I would
be satisfied with either scenario when
Arya Stark was just a child she told her
father that she never wanted to settle
down and live the life of a lady she
told Ned that she didn't want to have
kids but things could always change most
kids think the opposite sexes have
cooties and stuff like that when they're
young but we all know that change is
pretty quickly once you get a little bit
older and I'm hoping the same goes for
Arya Stark personally I would love to
see her settle down with ginjury most of
you that have watched all my videos
already know this because I made a video
about Arya and Kendra getting together
but if this did happen Arya might change
her last name or if they did have kids
they might not have the stark name
anyway
but that's even if Arya can have any
kids after suffering several deep
puncture wounds to her stomach the same
thing kind of goes for songs at two I
think Sansa has already been married two
times and one of those experiences was
severely traumatic and I'm not sure
anyone can say for sure exactly what
Ramsay did to her everyone knows Ramsay
physically mentally and emotionally
abuse onso but how bad did the abuse get
physically consensus still have kids
many people believe the theory that
Songza was pregnant by Ramsay but that
was never true but good Songza have been
hinting at something much worse when she
said she could still feel what Ramsay
did to her is it possible that Ramsay
raped her and beat her so bad that she
can no longer reproduce either when I
start to think about all this [ __ ] it
really sucks because in the television
show it seems like how star could be on
the verge
extinction brain stark is crippled and
he is so spaced out half the time I'm
not even sure if he would even consider
settling down with someone let alone
having a kid and that's even if he's
able to now just because he's crippled
doesn't necessarily mean he can't have
children but as far as we know it
doesn't seem like he can nor does it
seem like he's even interested in such a
thing but on the other hand where things
do get interesting is what Jon Snow
John is a member of House Stark and he
is king in the north
and he is currently the only one who is
sexually active and in my opinion I
believe he will have a child before the
series ends now I know some of you have
said there isn't enough time to do that
but trust me this show has no problem
speeding things up Jon most likely got
Daenerys pregnant the first time they
had sex in the last six episodes might
be around ninety minutes long so I
wouldn't be shocked if the Narus gave
birth to a child and one of the very
last scenes in this series but the only
problem is if Jon and Daenerys do have a
child together what name would the baby
carry John's last name is snow right now
but we all know he is actually a
legitimate Targaryen it's hard to say
how John is going to react to the news
that his name is actually Aegon
Targaryen I honestly don't see him using
that name for himself but I could be
wrong but I want to ask all of you this
if John and Daenerys do have a kid
together what name do you think the baby
will have Daenerys would most likely
wanted to carry the Targaryen name
especially after her and John were
talking about how she was the only
Targaryen left plus they're gonna
eventually find out John as a Targaryen
- but do you think John will try and
honor House Stark and give the baby the
stark name to carry on the house for
future generations I think this is a
very interesting situation they could be
in but instead of me giving my
predictions all the time let me know
what you think they will do with only
six episodes left how much time do they
really have to wrap all of this up in a
nice bow at the end what kind of dream
of spring will the show version give all
of us will there be any sign of hope at
the end after all the battles and wars
are done well any of the Starks be
married or pregnant by the end we have
always heard about getting a bittersweet
ending so they could leave us all with
something sweet by setting things up in
a way that shows the Starks and other
major families are
thinking and preparing to further the
bloodlines of their respective houses so
which member of House Stark will be the
one to carry on the family name and how
will they do that put it down below in
the comments I'm curious to see who some
of you might say but now it's time to
announce the last winner of the giveaway
just in case your name isn't called make
sure you stay until the end of the video
because I do have a few details to
announce about the next giveaway but
that's only if you're interested first I
have to apologize just in case I
mispronounced this person's name but the
third and final winner of this giveaway
is ole SiC who is from Poland
congratulations to you
make sure you private message me on here
or you can send me an email that way I
can get your address and send you the
prize I'm sorry everyone couldn't win
something but there is good news I will
start a new giveaway in the next video I
make and this one will have seven
different winners and you will be able
to claim your prize immediately you
won't have to wait for anything to come
into mail if that sounds good make sure
you subscribe now so you will already be
automatically entered I want to thank
everyone for watching don't forget to
leave your questions thoughts and
opinions down below in the comment
section I also want to thank all of my
patreon supporters too I appreciate each
and every one of you have a great day
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh